[موسيقى]
يبدو وكأنه مشهد من دراما الفترة
ولكن هؤلاء مربيات من القرن الحادي والعشرين
وتدريب المدرسة الشمالية
توفر المربيات للأثرياء والمشاهير
لأكثر من 100 عام ،
نورلاند إي آر ماريا بوريلو ليست بعيدة أبدًا
عن ثلاث اتهامات ملكية صغيرة لها
بسهولة  نولان آني ترتدي الزي البني الشهير الذي
ترتديه ، وهي تمثل
رمزًا للمكانة ولا يوجد ما
يكفي لتلبية الطلب ، فهناك سبعة
طلبات من العملاء لكل
خريج يكسب حوالي 65000 دولار سنويًا على الرغم من
أنه يمكن أن يكون
تدريبًا لمدة أربع سنوات أكثر بكثير  تتجاوز الدورة التدريبية
رعاية الأطفال إلى حد بعيد ، فهم يقومون بالقيادة على الجليد ،
لذا فإن هذا لا يعني محاولة الهروب
من المصورين ، فهذا يتعلق بمحاولة
مساعدة طلابنا على القيادة في ظل ظروف ربما
أكثر صعوبة
، وبالطبع
يأتي ضباط المخابرات العسكرية لمنحهم بعض
الأمن السيبراني والشخصي على سبيل المثال ،
لذا فأنت تتحدث عن فيلم جيمس بوند ماري
بوبينز ، وقد صاغه بعض الأشخاص على
هذا النحو ، لذا نريد التأكد من ذلك
خريجو r هم فريدون من
نوعه ، تشارلز في سنته الثالثة من
الدورة التي مدتها أربع سنوات ، سيكون واحدًا من
نخبة قليلة من المربيات الذكور الأوائل من N'awlins الذين
تخرجوا في العام الماضي فقط ما نوع
الأسرة التي تأمل في العمل  لأنه
عندما تغادر هنا شخصًا يجعلني جزءًا
من عائلته ، فأنا لست لكوني مجرد
موظف يعمل في نظر الجمهور هو
أن شيئًا قد يقلقك أو
تعتقد أنك ستكون بخير في العمل في
هذا النوع من البيئة.  أعتقد أنني سأكون على
ما يرام في العمل في تلك
البيئة ولأنني مربية أطفال أشعر
أنني سأواجه بالفعل نوعًا من تلك
الضغوط في طلب رفيع المستوى ، فقد
بدأت تمطر وقلق على
طفلنا ، أعتقد أننا يجب أن نترأسه
يقوم الطلاب الشماليون بعمل مواضع في
المدارس ودور الحضانة والمستشفيات ،
لكنهم أيضًا تم اختبارهم على الأطفال الافتراضيين في
الوقت الحالي ، فنحن نقوم ببعض العمل العملي ،
نعم
قيل لي أن هناك خطرًا من أن هذا الطفل
وطفلي إميلي قد يبدآن في البكاء
نعم واحد  من الأسباب الرئيسية يمكن أن
يحدث هذا أ  إذا فشلت في إصلاحها ، فقد أحرقت
شاشتك ، فأطعمتها شعرت أنه يمكنني
التجسس على الجينز و Apple بخير
قبل أن تخبرني لماذا قررت
المجيء إلى Norland بخلاف هذا ، فإن
النداء هو بالتأكيد ما
كان عليه تدريبهم.  منتشر للغاية
ويغطي مجموعة متنوعة من
المهارات المختلفة في غضون عامين ،
ستعتني هؤلاء المربيات
بأطفال حقيقيين ربما يكونون بارزين أو حتى من
العائلة المالكة آنا ستيوارت سي إن إن